all right and we are live
fresh from the PlayStation experience
and III I got two people in the building
right now the broth the Lord of all
bronze PlayStation positive evangelism I
am doing fantastic spectacular by the
way thanks for having me on to great
places and experience with me here so we
had to get the breath taken away come
you know yeah you know well hold on
let's get you a fire oh my god
presentations makes your control and of
course we have to got seats yet oh I'm
not doing well thank you we get into
this we first off this conference we got
a lot to talk about a question it's all
raw and real right now so we don't get
into a soul let's start with October as
far as the order of things which gave me
what it's not up that was sold by the
Sony conference well we'll start off
with the one they started off with and
that's the last of us part 2
okay cool so last was part two let's get
brought in here this is your people team
but over there what were your
impressions of blast was 2mm that PSX
trailer from two years ago the field of
look today they open that video with
them and they are the 10mm party dude
people on the council that never played
the last of us will reckon out oh my god
look at these graphics look at just a
couple there's guts hanging out man they
they upped the ante Naughty Dog the
liver man Lord say what do you feel
about the last two presentation I will
echo his thoughts it's one of my most
anticipated games it's it's trying to
get to the number two position right now
I love it I love the first game this one
looks even crazier looks brutal
visceral a flashback sequence in between
the nice little romantic encounter was
wonderfully done the detail but naughty
God puts in their innovation thank you
and the combat and you felt the
sledgehammer yeah
yes I love it fantastic highlight of the
show you know what I like what she
called home with them yeah that rug did
a date it was really cool I mean that's
our child feeding which agree with more
salmon and Lara I think it was one of
those think that it was it had the nice
mix of being extra visceral but at the
same time I liked the transition scenes
that she's back at the party stuff like
that it's just really cool I'm excited
to see what the franchisor is going to
go I thought it was a very strong
showing in my opinion so what do we got
up next down the show we gotta take a
20-minute intermission let's talk about
the elephant in the villa what was up
with the transitions between games
between music the music was fine the
transitions yeah it was not it's cool if
you're shuffling press in between rooms
based off the themes to set the mood
that's cool
guess what 99.99% of your audience is
watching on stream we're not cool for
them we were all sitting here hi we just
watched The Last of Us 2 emotions
roaring I'm just so excited all of a
sudden well hey through like that the
pacing was a bit yeah I didn't like the
pace in again but on let's go into now
the next game up on the docket
which I believe was I've been looking
forward to this game so a minute the
minute it was announced as our people is
damn this is sucker-punch arrest us okay
first of all the dick of body is that I
love the future Perenara
that everything I loved the whole in the
Beijing day
David had like a Bushido blade kind of
feel you never sit with the swordplay
everything was but I also saw it in slow
motion deflection looked at fantastic so
I'm really anticipating it
there was muscles a little bit of
platforming mechanics that I saw on and
I liked and even the whole I just okay
cool so that's nothing I want to hear
now but what about you Brian
what did you feel about this issue I'll
be honest Sharon sucker sucker punch is
a great components to do and if mistake
is so good with you but at some points
it was like okay it still tells her
early next you know you plan but that
came was clearly in each detail they
harness the power to ps4 you just
pushing that baby feeling absolutely
like when he's gone to the fields on
move the beliefs one just yeah just got
insane bro the second best game of the
show in my opinion one like to wait open
day just emphasis of Japan's under
attack all right up next game number
three game number three of these deep
dives that was deaths friend the
interesting
lesson that I've been one of death
strandings biggest proponents and
biggest defenders over the last couple
of years
emphasizing Kojima's you know Unleashed
creativity let them explore these weird
Lovecraftian themes let them explore
these alien worlds who the hell knows
what's going on here anything but we're
supposed to get a deep dive not a man a
little bit of walking and a confused cut
snip and paste trailer and then we took
this bit here and now it's here the okay
know enough the last trailer at the Game
Awards was fantastic it was phenomenal I
think now I'm beginning to get a little
so we have to have an idea of what the
game is doesn't mean it takes away the
mystery
stop it I'm seeing all this Twitter
nonsense topic you know the game still
has a ton of mystery but we don't
understand how it plays two years on you
would not be defending any other title
out there they did this listen Kazuma
guess he forgets the past he gets a pair
I'm not saying it right I'm not saying
it's right but yeah like I didn't know
what was going on
so I'm rich won it but you know that
they could see the people coming it's
not like he did watch the trailer and
said no unless this tourism I mean it
did looked the game looks phenomenal the
graphics are amazing
it's the decimate engine wouldn't expect
prices he rode on okay but yeah the game
plate was just watching sam's
walk hospitals in his backpack and
dropping scared and babies it's very
much a military forte yes yes and then
you got the invisible
see I like that part okay I saw this bot
don't lose all stealthy here to meet you
know ghost hunter chords kind of they
all know but so oh I know what you feel
great it look great mm-hmm I'm still
optimistic about the game I'm so excited
but yeah I mean like the same it's a
little bit like okay continuum I need to
see a little bit more okay you need to
give us more and let's move to the last
one of the docket Spidey
spider-man spider-man does whatever a
spider community all right it was good
but why was this the closer this
humanity loner if I didn't I don't have
a problem with the footage it was fine
we looked good
lots of villains mysterious will
clickbait tease at the end here but you
know what it's fight he has a great mood
it's a line but it should have been okay
let me jump in um actually the plugs are
actually Wonderbra well what did you
feel about spider-man it was presented
okay showing off his like like the Rogue
rogue gallery oh man I was so excited
it looked amazing this is the spider-man
game of all I want to play oh and it's
insomniac games man you're getting kind
of trust in them okay game looks
genuinely fun but yeah just I'm like
okay the clothes no spider-man get it it
comes out three months okay we're
mindful battle but yeah I kind of
expected the last of us of this
stranding gotcha but it goes it's gonna
deliver people playing it right now and
they're saying yeah I mean I'm going to
say some controversy like it's not that
there's nothing it was trash anything it
looked phenomenal right the thing about
it is just that I didn't like the way
run like it I wouldn't make it how good
when he's doing the order for but now
here's what I did like I like that they
got you know saying you know yeah
Oh Walter vulture all that yeah you know
me so that's pretty much it I'm not
gonna read it too much but um you know
one of those things that I was surprised
that they and